jessica first i want to know whose idea
was it to include uh justin and jason in
this cast because that came as a very
pleasant surprise
i'm glad you say that that was the whole
idea we just wanted that
little you know
tickly moment when he when those two
show up um justin justin's idea he
wanted to play that part
i thought he was kidding i really
we were hiring a local person we just
and you know we had spent all our money
on our main cast and um
he just said no i've got to do this part
i know what to do i i know how i can
make this happen and then i think
melanie tell the tell the moustache
story
well it was christmas and i took a
picture um of my husband who was hanging
out with me in atlanta and was bored and
had grown
an extremely impressive moustache
um i took a picture of him with our
daughter and i stinted and i said oh hi
everybody
and robin who was on our group text was
like oh my god jason's 80s look is
really
like inspiring me so she asked if he
would maybe be interested in playing the
other detective
um
and then it turned into the the bromance
of the ages
[Laughter]
i feel like that was like the little
lightness that i needed at that point in
the show so i was very happy to see that
happen
now kind of delving into the darkness a
little bit here uh melanie first for you
can tell me a little bit about the prep
you had to do and just your personal
goals for the sequence where betty is
standing in the courtroom and you know
maybe specifically the beat where the
verdict is actually said because there's
a lot of impressive work going on around
you but no your your presence there just
amplifies the emotion of that moment so
significantly and i think it become i
think it comes from the nuance that you
bring to it thank you well that was
michael uppendale also directed episode
five
and i was very very grateful because
again i just trust him
the most
and there were moments where i felt very
vulnerable it's a very weird position to
be in and i just was like does this look
crazy and he was just like i promise you
if it does it's not going to be in the
show i promise you and
so i just was able to really go there
because i
i knew he wouldn't you know i just i
just think he's such a craftsman
um
and also i really love that robin had
that idea that robin was as protective
of betty as i was she wanted her to have
a voice and i just think it's a very
moving
and beautiful way to do that and robin's
just such an open-hearted beautiful
human being
you